drowned ex-wives amanda siffred's
scariest role since mamma mia
and kevin bacon since footloose thank
you sir i have another
yeah i know that wasn't footloose i just
kind of wanted to put it in there you
should have left his blumhouse's latest
horror installment and also what i would
have said to myself if i watched this in
theaters
i'm kidding i didn't think it was that
bad now this film is getting really
differing reviews with those who like it
really liking it and those who don't
well beautiful house
go google some pictures of it but do not
waste your time watching this movie
in this video we're going to break down
its cryptic ending and explain what the
house is
the mysterious staedtler and
sorry guys it's just every time there's
a movie with kevin bacon in it that's
all i can think about
nice but before we go on be sure to like
and subscribe with that bell on to stay
updated on my latest horror
sci-fi and movie breakdowns you should
have left is the story of
theo conroy a retired banker who takes
his family on a quick vacation to the
welsh countryside
before his actress wife starts a new job
in london you see where his wife susanna
is famous
theo is infamous years ago he was put on
trial for the murder of his ex-wife but
was deemed
innocent because he was a big shot
banker his trial was a huge story so you
know to keep a low profile he ends up
marrying a famous actress
now the film begins with a hint at the
film's antagonist a creepy limping man
who will come to know as stetler he
comes to visit theo's daughter ella but
as we'll find out this is one of those
fake outs where it's all just a dream
[Music]
the god damn dream in fact theo is
plagued by nightmares like this
throughout the entire film nightmares
which show his daughter dead and
ex-wife drowning in the bathtub in the
beginning we see he takes some sort of
medication to help with this and
notice his reflection in the mirror the
film plays a lot with mirrors and
reflections
often the reflection will do something
different than the person it's
reflecting and as stetler says near the
end of the film
that's the problem with mirrors
they always show you yourself oh yeah
stitler is actually theo but we'll get
into that in a bit theo is unable to
face his true reflection his true crimes
and his guilt eats away at him
the film actually does a pretty good job
hinting at this to help rid himself of
these nightmares theo writes in a
journal he documents his feelings and
listens to a meditation app
if you try to stop your thoughts or
prevent them from entering your mind
you will only create conflict when you
are trying to achieve people
nearly four minutes in and the film has
already told us what it's really about
theo's nightmares are the result of him
trying to stop something that is causing
him built up
pressure and anxiety as we'll find out
later this is him trying to hide the
fact that he actually killed his ex-wife
something that he's trying to stop
through medication and
meditation and this leads to one of the
greatest ironies of the film
while his actress wife literally makes a
living pretending to be other people
theo two is an actor of sorts living a
lie
pretending that he never killed his wife
after all as he says
you can't tell what you don't believe so
these two actors and their daughter ella
head to the welsh countryside which was
actually shot in new jersey
lol for a much needed vacation and this
house is pretty creepy the color scheme
is drab and gray
a lot of the rooms feel empty and there
are no pictures on the walls
they even took down the pictures as
we'll find out later the pictures will
re-emerge as theo finds out they belong
to the souls of those who have perished
in the house
their first night something strange
happens that only we the viewer
are privy to susanna goes to bed at 10
34 pm while theo goes to turn off the
lights in the rest of the house
he discovers this weird polaroid in one
of the rooms which we'll later find out
is of stetler
aka himself however when theo arrives
back to the bedroom
five hours have passed even though we've
only seen him gone for
a few minutes that's because the house
has the ability to manipulate
time through dreams it creates this
creepy dynamic where we have to question
when and if the characters are really
dreaming there's also a fun little
easter egg with the book on theo's
bedside table since we fell a
psychological thriller whose protagonist
needs to confront her own fears
just like theo later on we see some more
books as susannah packs up to leave like
the blinds just like the family is to
theo's true past
and no one is coming to save us i think
that one's pretty self-explanatory
on a walk in the countryside ella asks
susanna why people hate her dad
and susanna opens up about his past and
how he was accused of murdering his
ex-wife this leads to a conflict between
the two since theo was the one who
wanted to tell ella this was one of the
few things he can actually control
in a life where everything seems out of
his control in his diary he vents his
frustration stating that he's
tired confused and pissed and that he
can't shake this quote
dark dark feeling so theo leaves the
house to head into the local grocery
store which if you translate the store
name from welsh
it reads bread of heaven and this is no
coincidence heaven comes up multiple
times throughout the film
mainly through ella's questioning of
what happens when we die
we're all going to be together again
in heaven it's the grocery store clerk
who gives us more insight into this
mysterious house
the current house is only four years old
but it was built on another house before
that
and another and a tower and so on and so
forth
it's basically a graveyard of houses
built upon one another the clerk asks if
he's met stitler yet who theo assumes is
the owner
this is echoed by the mysterious woman
outside the store who asks the same
thing
it appears that townsfolk know all about
this house and who stitler is
they're complicit in its taking of
victims they know that the house takes
those who have committed evil deeds
that's why when theo calls the clerk for
help near the end of the film the clerk
basically hangs up the clerk ends up
giving theo one of these triangle ruler
things which i hope to god never to see
again after failing geometry this is
later used by theo when he finds the
walls in the house aren't at 90 degree
angles
try the right angles later in the film
he finds out that the length from wall
to wall inside the house is different
than wall to wall
outside the house is the house actually
changing or is this simply an
architectural flaw theo comes back home
to find someone has written in his
journal the line
leave you should leave go now theo will
later think this is written by max
susanna's secret lover of whom she has a
burner phone to communicate with but as
we'll find out it was actually
theo himself already trapped within the
house but if he's already trapped that
begs the question
are what we seeing simply a loop of his
journey that he's been forced to relive
this nightmare over and over
again as penance for his sins the
evidence for this is pretty compelling
in the next scene theo ventures down to
the secret basement where he finds a
polaroid on the ground of him and his
daughter
sleeping in bed this image or scene if
you will doesn't happen until the very
end of the film
yet he's seeing it now it's already
happened so theo goes on to confront
susanna about her cheating when he finds
out she has a secret second phone
they fight and he makes her spend the
night away from the house
and of course this is where things start
to go bonkers the house has the ability
to manipulate its
rooms what once led to the kitchen now
leads to the storage room stuff like
that
theo loses ella who finds stetler this
crutch-wielding guy who looks like he
just came back
from epstein island such a lucky daddy
i bet you'd stay with him forever
luckily theo manages to find ella and
calls the grocery clerk for help and
learns a little more about the house
essentially saying that it's
unexplainable like an ant doesn't know
what a cathedral is so
too can we not comprehend the powers
surrounding this house
but the clerk does hint that the house
is run by the devil
the devil builds the tower to collect
souls
and god destroys it but the devil just
built it up again
this is a metaphor for the house being
built and rebuilt the constant battle
between
god and the devil this would make
stetler the devil theo tries to leave
the house and walk into town with ella
but the house brings them back
we see here a shadow looking at them
from within the house which we'll later
learn is
theo's trapped soul unable to get away
theo and ellis stay the night where theo
loses ella once again
taking him on a journey through time his
watch goes haywire and he sees scenes
from the past
like them arriving at the house or him
and ella trying to walk into town
this leads to his eventual confrontation
with stetler
stetler is basically theo's
manifestation of the devil
an ugly limping man that has crippled
theo emotionally a symbol of his ugly
past he can't forget
that's why when theo beats the crap out
of him he turns into himself he's
finally confronting his reflection
one of his ugly past he watched his wife
drown where he could have saved her but
he didn't and this guilt eats away at
him
stitler's final words to theo before he
lets him go with ella are
then you know what you've gotta do don't
you that's why when susannah comes to
pick them up the next day
theo tells the truth and opens up i
killed her sis
i let her drown theo's hell has been
living this lie and now he feels he
needs to be punished and this punishment
shouldn't affect those he loves
if he tried to stay with susannah and
ella the house would just bring them all
back
it'll never let me i'd end up right back
here
and if you were with me you would too i
belong here
in his confession to susannah theo talks
about how years of anger built up inside
of him
resulting in his decision to let his
ex-wife drown
and keeping it inside
i should have left
years before and i hope you caught that
line i should have left
basically the title of the movie you
should have left isn't really about
leaving the house it's about leaving
situations that can negatively
affect your life and make you do bad
things theo should have left his ex-wife
but he didn't
theo should have left the house when he
got the message in the journal but he
didn't
theo now believes he belongs in the
house i belong
right here
can't run away from a shadow and the use
of shadows were
foreshadowed throughout the film oh god
the puns
like when ella plays with shadow puppets
the mysterious shadow-like figures in
the house
or how the camera creepily focuses on
theo's shadow instead of theo
when he comes back from the store the
shadow represents the guilt he's kept in
the dark all these years only revealing
itself at the very
end of the film we get this creepy shot
of the hallway covered in polaroids of
what can only be assumed are its past
victims the voiceover of the shopkeeper
says the house has a way of finding the
right people
some leave some stay it's also pretty
tongue-in-cheek that the song that plays
in the background here is
should i stay or should i go now and the
film ends on the house becoming
available again but notice who it's
listed by
stetler looking for his next soul but
one question i want to leave you with is
if you think stetler is really the devil
i mean if i were the devil i'd just try
to take all three of the family members
forever yet this character has a motive
stetler wants theo to see the heir of
his ways to come
clean and be honest he even lets him go
so he can do this
would the devil really do that if you
rearrange the letters of stitler you get
the words
let rest now maybe that's just a
coincidence but it seems this character
wants the souls of these people to
finally be at rest
and achieve that peace that theo's been
desperately wanting since the beginning
so i leave it up to you
is stitler the devil or something else i
want to hear your thoughts in the
comments below that's it for this video
guys make sure to like and subscribe and
for more bad takes be sure to follow me
on twitter
at thinkstoryyt until next time remember
daddy loves you very much